binds being a popular a carpet why does
being extreme
what up yo it's November 11 2022. I'm
David this is the Reuben report we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV subscribe if you have not and
today we're doing mostly a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
but then we just wanted to do like a
general crazy stuff of the week that we
didn't get to touch on so we got plenty
in it I warn you in advance it includes
AOC it includes Whoopi Goldberg it
includes Joe Biden it includes John
Federman and it includes MSNBC so that's
what we're doing today real quick guys
let me talk to you about moink box and
then we'll get to it uh you know that 60
of U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day
there's a better way I'd like to tell
you about moink that's moo plus oink
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door Mike Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm Does It Better the moink
difference is a difference you can taste
and you can feel good knowing you're
helping family farm stay financially
independent as well you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes to
chicken breasts to pork chops to salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel any time my personal favorite is
their filet mignon Shark Tank host Kevin
O'Leary called moink's bacon the best
bacon he's ever had and ring doorbell
founder Jimmy simenov Jamie simenov
jumped at the chance to invest in oink
plus they'll guarantee you'll say oink
oink I'm just so happy I got moaned keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free get
free filet mignon for a year in every
order that's one of the best filet
mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time spelled
m-o-i-n-k box icon slash Reuben that's
moinkbox.com Reuben all right let's just
do a Friday end of the week General
Insanity listo stuff here is AOC there
is a major
media Outlet there is a major News
Channel that is fueling political
violence in this country and we're
acting like it's normal it's not normal
like I can tell you one hundred and ten
percent one of the largest sources of
death threats that I get is Tucker
Carlson wow every time that dude puts my
name in his mouth the next day I mean
this is like what stochastic terrorism
is it's like this indirect it's like
when you have when you use a very large
platform to turn up the temperature and
Target an individual
until something happens and then when
something happens because it's indirect
you say oh I had nothing to do with that
right Tucker Carlson God forbid anything
happens he plays a massive role in
political violence like it comes on his
doorstep specifically let me be clear
AOC and yes I am very depressed that you
won your re-election and Tina Forte who
I interviewed that that awesome Italian
Mama should have replaced you but okay
the people of the Bronx want something
else so be it uh let me be clear Tucker
Carlson has never once called for
violence on you or anyone else now that
is in stark contrast to Democrats who
have often called for violence and get
in their face and make them nervous and
show up at their houses you guys get the
Litany of things the Democrats have done
recently including AOC herself the point
of protest is to make people
uncomfortable those are her words and
yet when protesters show up at her
events uh you know she gets behind armed
guards and the rest of it uh the irony
of course of really what she's saying
there is that while she is blaming him
for turning up the temperature is she
not turning up the temperature on him if
if she is a forthright in her belief
that he is saying mean things about her
and under threat from her well as she
addresses that and talks about him as
you know in essence a domestic terrorist
and a fire thrower and all of these
things well what would happen if one of
aoc's supporters went after Tucker
Carlson would that be aoc's problem do
you see the flaw in the logic there but
that is what they do over and over and
then of course what AOC also does is
blame other people for the problems that
she and her party creates here she is
blaming police officers for Rising crime
a lot of people think that crime is up
when we actually see that shootings are
down when we see that huge indicators on
on the most violent crime in New York
City is down Subway crime is up but
let's also note that Subway crime is up
after they committed
so many more officers to the subway
system so that also tells us from a
policy perspective adding more cops to
the subway isn't solving this problem so
there are other things that can solve
this problem it's just so incredible
guys just go to New York City if you
dare and see if you feel safe the way
you might have when Rudy Giuliani was
mayor also she's not of course
commenting on the fact that murder is
way up and we know that the problem is
not more police the problem is that
people like you defunded the police you
handicapped law enforcement to be able
to do anything to stop crime and then
you guys go after them and demonize them
all the time so then we have this
massive amount of police officers in New
York City and I know several of them
personally who retire early they take
early retirement because they don't want
to be involved anymore they don't want
to get crushed and be splattered all
over the news and not defended by their
mayor and everything else and then you
get a new crop of people who are less
qualified on the way in because fewer
and fewer people want those jobs this
this is on you sister it's on you but
okay so AOC Dave why are you giving me
bad news why are you showing me AOC on a
Friday give me some good news Dave well
how about this one uh Whoopi Goldberg's
leaving Twitter
so it has been a little over a week
since Elon Musk took over Twitter and
places it it's a mess he's already
called back some of the workforce he
fired a few days ago he's putting his
Eight dollar charge for blue check
verification on hold first it was going
to be twenty dollars now it's going to
be eight dollars he also suspended Kathy
Griffin for impersonating him on a
parody account uh
which has started a free Cappy hashtag
to Trent I mean I'm I'm I I'm getting
off I'm getting off today because I just
feel like you know it's it's so messy
yeah and I I'm tired of now
having had certain kinds of attitudes
blocked and now they're back on and I
just I'm gonna get out and if it settles
down and I feel more comfortable yeah
maybe I'll come back but as of tonight
I'm done with
there's so much here so first off I
found out during the clip uh whoopee is
worth approximately 60 million dollars
so let's go on the assumption that she
can afford the eight dollars or the
twenty dollars it's eight but I'm gonna
go on the Assumption she can afford it
that's one thing uh but now what she's
really upset by was what she said at the
end there were certain types of
attitudes that were blocked before and
now they're back there are people
literally on Twitter right now who
believe things that Whoopi Goldberg does
not believe she can't be on a platform
with those people she's on The View only
with people who who agree with her all
day long
it's so incredible you know I always
talk about that thin viewer of veneer of
Tolerance that progressives have like
they seem tolerant and then you peel
this thing off and then it's just sort
of this crazy hysterical angry lunatic
it's like that is what Whoopi is and
it's unfortunate she was a great actress
right when she was in ghost Molly you in
danger girl I remember I saw it at the
movie theaters I loved it Sister Act
Sister Act two I've done this before
what else has she been in she was in uh
soap dish come on give me a give me a
Whoopi Goldberg movie she was in help me
here guys what else was she in she was
in uh The Color Purple I'm doing this
off the top of my head she was in uh did
they do a sister act three
which one
she was in The Little Rascals thank you
Phoenix all right the point is she was a
decent actress and now she's just
because these people so this idea of now
there's voices on there that were booted
that are back it's like so you were okay
censoring people do you not see that
makes you the bad guy and speaking of
bad guys Joe Biden got asked they invite
I mean this is so incredible they
invited a bunch of tick-tock influencers
that that's a thing they invited a bunch
of tick tock influencers oh and I should
tell you guys I am not on Tick Tock I'm
sure I'm being impersonated on Tick Tock
I am not on Tick Tock I will never get
on Tick Tock I've had a million offers
for a lot of money to get on Tick Tock
and do all sorts of stuff on Tick Tock
it is it is a weapon of the Chinese
government that uses our data against us
it steals Americans data it also shows
American children all of this crazy
gender stuff and woke nonsense while in
China if you're on Tick Tock it shows
kids how to do math and it shows them
all sorts of interesting things about
engineering and Science and more it is
it is in infiltrating our country so
anyway I'm not going to get on there but
a bunch of tick-tock influencers were
invited to the White House and started
asking Joe Biden some very important
questions like uh could we silence Elon
Musk
um Mr President do you think Elon Musk
is a threat to U.S national security and
should the U.S and with the tools you
have investigate his joint acquisition
of Twitter with foreign governments
which include the Saudis
thank you
I think that
Elon musk's
cooperation and or
technical
relationships with other countries
uh
is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he is doing anything
inappropriate I'm not suggesting that
I'm suggesting that it worse worse being
looked at and uh
um and uh but that's all I'll say
there's a lot of ways uh all right
all right so let's put aside the uh the
stammering and the slurring and that all
that let's put that aside for a second
um he doesn't know that elon's up to no
good but we should look into it you know
I'm pretty sure one thing they can do
when they start looking is find
something they'll always find a way to
find something it's odd because I don't
think he was very interested in the
United States government looking into uh
Hunter Biden's laptop uh and any of
Hunter Biden's business dealings with
Ukrainian energy companies that was not
something that was worthy of government
looking into now you've got a guy that's
fighting for free speech the same guy
who's sending us to Mars said hey I'm
going to also solve some problems down
here I'm going to open up the major
communications platform on Earth Twitter
to more and more people I'm going to let
more and more things be said okay uh and
now we should look into him what's also
interesting about that is Joe Biden does
not get any questions off the cuff so
they planted that Tick-Tock influencer
and they gave him that question just
absolutely ridiculous but speaking of
ridiculous boy the Segways are writing
themselves today
MSNBC this week after John fetterman
beat Dr Oz may God have mercy on
Pennsylvanian Souls uh they actually had
a panel discussing whether John
fetterman might be up to being president
in 2024.
a nominee at some point for president
um I know there's some variables
obviously but it's a few but I just you
know it
what he did in the in the super red deep
red parts of Pennsylvania and the way
that he ran ahead of Biden as you were
saying around ahead of trump I mean it
just makes it makes you wonder about his
future
that woman her name is Katie tur I
believe should have been removed from
the room during live television they
should have put her in a straight jacket
and just outright removed her sorry lady
even for this network that is a bit much
the fact that they sat there and
discussed that is completely insane you
know you could tell they were sort of
laughing through it but the fact that
this guy is even in Senate is is just
nuts Katy tur should just be removed and
taken away all right let's move on
though to the reubenreport.locals.com
Community Q a but before I get to it let
me talk to you about real estate agents
I trust you guys know already they're
buying or selling a home is one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be way worse if you're not working
with the right agent usually our homes
are our biggest investment which is a
ton of responsibility and you need an
agent who takes that seriously which is
why I recommend real estate agents I
trust they work with only the best
agents in every Market they do their
homework to talking to every agent
before inviting them to join their
Network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records are the best sellers in their
field and even under these intense
economic conditions with high interest
rates and high inflation real estate
agents I trust has provided their
customers with agents who've overcome
these challenges in the past they're
part of this audience they share your
values and they're almost anywhere you
want to go just head on over to
realestateagentsitrust.com give them
some basic info their team will contact
you and if you live in a blue State you
move to a red State and you live happily
ever after all right
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
Catherine says which of your poor staff
do you make watch The View for the
outtakes you make us watch this is a
great question I like this sort of
Insider question and it's an interesting
answer because the way we do the show in
the morning is every morning Phoenix and
I very early we go back and forth on all
the clips so I'm sending him stuff
throughout the day he gets how many
emails do you get from you on average
day probably
about 30 40 emails he whittles them down
a little bit we bounce back and forth he
helps me sort of map everything out so
he has to watch so I've watched the
clips to start because I sent it to him
then this Porsche Buck has to watch him
himself and then he has to send it to
this guy Connor over here who how many
times do you have to watch him because
you got to get him into the system you
got to cut them and trim them and
too many dude we all watch them it's
horrible help
lazy broad says how do we help Herschel
Walker win his runoff is money the only
answer will the RNC get behind him it's
a great question look so they're going
to run off with Raphael Warnock uh it
was within one percent or whatever it
might be it's on December 6th
look if you live in Georgia just vote
just vote what a what a nice little
extra defense this would be regardless
of which way the Senate is going right
now if we can just get one more
Republican in there not that they have
to do much and they'll constantly be
fighting with the administration and
everything else but just get Herschel in
there just so that they can maybe slow
down the train to Crazy Town that Joe
Biden has this country on so what can
you do I think really I mean I guess you
can donate money I don't love the idea
of people from out of state donating to
State races like it doesn't feel I hate
that when all of these people who don't
live in certain places bounce around and
show up in other places like you don't
live there but I understand politics is
a seriously dirty game so of course you
know there's probably some money that
can be done talk to your friends in
Georgia take a vacation to Georgia on
December 6th so you can make sure that
all of your friends are gonna get out
there and vote Florida man Chuck I like
that Florida man says given the election
results are you still as optimistic
about the direction of the country or do
you think things will keep moving in the
wrong direction well look as I explained
on the show yesterday I I am I am
unbelievably bullish and thrilled and
excited about the future in Florida and
I think that future will be mapped more
and more in solidly red places so Texas
you're going to be just fine Tennessee
you're going to be just fine there are
other places obviously there and then
there's the usual places I think
Kentucky and Alabama whatever okay
you're going to be just fine like not to
say these places don't have their own
set of problems and everybody could
always do better but the basic set of
like are we Americans do we believe in
Law and Order that this place is decent
that's good that's good and strong here
the national level is messy like now you
know Biden even if the Republicans end
up with the Senate and the house like
Biden is here for two more years they
can still do all sorts of damage for two
years we've exported so much of the
power to the presidency when he really
was just supposed to sign things into
laws and give us some speeches to make
this thing an aspirational movement make
America an idea and and you know let
that idea burst forth he was supposed to
be the grand Communicator for that he
wasn't supposed to be the guy that said
all the policy so I think the country as
a whole right now is is still in trouble
right I think there was really look it
was going to be in trouble no matter
what even if the Republicans had crushed
so we get the Red Wave it wouldn't have
stopped all the stuff right I mean watch
my videos from last week that's what I
was saying it's not like the woke we're
just gonna stop but I think it would
have been enough of a bulwark for a
whole bunch of us in all sorts of
different states to say wow we've really
pushed back they might have had to have
readjusted a little bit and it would
have given us a little Runway to uh to
start fixing things I think it really
depends on where you live and since
you're a Florida man you're going to be
just fine vinyl says hi Dave is
democracy dying in darkness in
California lights were out at the Young
Turk Studios look many of you know I
used to be on The Young Turks I'm not
proud of it is what it is uh the Jank
over there is just a nut bag they rail
on me all the time I don't pay any
attention to it I don't it doesn't
matter I don't talk about them but I did
see that on Election night they're in
Los Angeles apparently the power went
out at their studio and it's like man
you morons voted in for this stuff you
love the Dems you love the progressives
you're in a progressive City and now you
can't turn on the electricity good luck
with all of that Robin says de Santa sir
Trump 2024 I think Trump is actually
hurting us now his policies are perfect
but his ego is not 2024 should not be
this close with the state of our country
it should have been a tsunami his
comments on DeSantis and pretty much
announcing his run I believe turned lots
of Independence and Suburban women away
I can't disagree with that look
I voted for Donald Trump I have met
Donald Trump I like Donald Trump I think
that what he did in 2016
to fight the woke before we even really
knew what it was and to fight the Deep
State and all of the stuff we needed it
he became a hero a very villainized hero
but he became a hero to those of us who
love America nobody's time is forever
though and it does seem like the mantle
should be passed to DeSantis at this
point that said as I keep saying I don't
know if DeSantis even wants to do it he
loves this freaking state so one thing
at a time he just won re-election here
however I will tell you this
when people I mean people bring this up
to me everywhere I go I go out to the
supermarket people ask me about trumpet
disasters now it's like
they have to figure it out not only do
they have to figure it out but Trump has
such a unique opportunity here if you
were to look at Trump's story all of the
things he has done how he was loved by
the media his whole life and Celebrity
Apprentice and on every TV show and
Oprah asking him to run for president
and on The Tonight Show and all he was
loved and then he was hated and he was
Hitler and then he loses the election
and then this new guy comes who's
younger who's a family man who it's just
a little bit cleaner and clearer with
him who's done incredible stuff in the
great state of Florida which by the way
happens to be the very state that Donald
Trump now lives in right he used to
spend most of his he's had marlago
forever down here but he used to spend
most of his time up in New York
obviously but now he lives here and he
he's happy to be here in part because of
DeSantis
what a great hero's journey he could go
on if right at this moment if they could
sit down they work it out and then he
says Ron I'm going to help you out I'm
going to help you out because I love
this country and not everything is about
me and I'll run rallies I'll take the
hits from the media I will block as you
run right through the middle and then we
restore this freaking thing I think
that's such a beautiful message is it
within him I mean basically everyone
says no but the guy is known to surprise
people I think there's a chance I I
think there's a chance I hope there's a
chance Naomi says for the corporate
media to hate Trump so much they sure
give him a lot of air time and attention
do you think if they would just ignore
him that he would slowly fade away from
American politics I mean it's a little
bit of a follow-up to the previous
question but it is interesting there's a
love-hate thing there with him do the
people at CNN really hate Donald Trump
or they love him when Donald Trump's in
the picture when something's going on
with Donald Trump whether it's a raid at
Mar-A-Lago or whether it is him fighting
with someone on Twitter in the old days
or whatever's going on now they get
ratings so there is a love hate thing
there you may hate him you may fear Him
you may think he's Hitler but you kind
of dig him because he's getting you some
scratch right that's kind of how it is
with these people
um I don't think that they should act
look I would prefer that we have an
objective media so I don't think you you
go out of your way to ignore people uh
in the in the effort to silence them but
if he has something interesting to say
and and uh if he's involved in certain
races and there's a reason to talk about
him then you do but you don't endlessly
focus on him I mean try to imagine the
amount I don't know what the numbers are
on this I'm sure some media Watchdog has
checked but if you were to check the
amount of time that even today right in
November of 2022 when Trump's been out
of office now for two plus years uh if
you were to actually look at the numbers
and see how much time a day does CNN and
MSNBC spend talking about Donald Trump
versus how much time a day do they spend
talking about Joe Biden and how much of
each of their coverage is positive
negative it would be really interesting
you have to remember CNN you like to
think they're a news organization but
they're a television channel that needs
to get views to make money that's really
what is going on over there Sweetwater
says do you have a hobby that you only
enjoy with certain people or in certain
places
do I have a hobby but I only enjoy with
certain people
or certain places
I don't know what you're really getting
a secret hobby
um well I've really been into cooking
lately you know David's spending so much
time with the kids and like right now
he's got he's bouncing babies I'm up
here talking to you people he's got kids
pee and poop and all that stuff spit up
Justin's spitting up now you know babies
don't really spit up that much right at
the beginning then you get them a couple
months in they start drooling a lot more
that's the thing I didn't know that
um but because of that David's cooking
where he used to spend so much time in
the kitchen and I've been blessed to eat
a lot of great meals over the last 12
years I've been doing a lot more of the
cooking lately so whether it's uh
whether it's smoking meat or I'm doing
some awesome roasted chickens lately in
the in the cast iron put some potatoes
and some veggies around them
um that's been my main hobby that's
really I don't really have a I'm playing
basketball again that's nice I play
basketball on Tuesday nights so I'm
running around again and uh
all right talk to YouTube sometimes
about stuff so that's pretty much it uh
Tessa says what can be done about the
Stranglehold Democrat activists have
over the media
well something actually great is
happening this is a little Insider
baseball Twitter stuff and I often say
to you guys you know I talk about
Twitter a lot and it's important to talk
about and elon's doing a great job but
if you're not on there don't feel like
you have to get on there you're probably
happier for it but one thing that's
super interesting that will eliminate
some of the Stranglehold is uh as you
know we've covered it a bit Twitter is
now allowing anyone to get that blue
check that verification check for eight
dollars a month so previously it was
people that were public people worked at
media organizations were famous actors
etc etc but it was somewhat arbitrary
and who got it it took me a long time to
get it if you worked with a big
organization you could get it if it was
much easier for lefties to get it than
conservatives all that stuff but one
thing that that really did to
disregulate everything with the media
was that if you worked a Daily Beast or
huffpo or vice
any of these craptastic places of
Journalism you would get a blue check
now you might only have 2 000 followers
and virtually no influence but then once
you had the blue check it seemed that
you were more legit on Twitter there was
a way that you could filter things where
you'd only see the blue check people so
suddenly so for example I would be
getting hit pieces written about me by
these basically these like alcoholic
losers who work at Daily Beast or huffpo
who have no followers but because they
have blue checks they get their other
little blue check friends to push these
articles out and it seems like someone's
reading these things now that anyone can
have a blue check if you've got eight
dollars a month their value has just
decreased so the value I suppose of my
blue check has decreased but that's okay
I've got a bunch of followers on there
whatever Twitter is not real life anyway
and I I don't even communicate I only do
one-way communication on Twitter I don't
respond to people there that's what I
have locals for that's where I get to
know people
um but the point is by now having anyone
be able to get that blue check it
actually the the layer of journalists
that got it got the undeserved prestige
that's what it is that it provided they
will just be like everybody else and
there is nothing that a journalist hates
more than being treated like a regular
person Grace says now that there was no
Red Wave uh do you think that there will
be another push for vaccine mandates
good god well
let's say this I don't think it's coming
you know in the next week or so but
there is no doubt that covid or monkey
pox or covid 6 or monkey covet or covid
monkey or whatever is coming or whether
it will be climate lockdowns or some
other weirdo thing and the governors
just imagine if you're Kathy Hotel you
did all of this evil
evil [ __ ] and then people voted you in
for the first time actually because she
was not voted in uh last time obviously
she stepped in after they got rid of
Cuomo if you're Gretchen Whitmer you did
some of the worst Draconian stuff and
the people said hey could you do that
again to us could you lock us home again
put us in masks inject my kids with some
[ __ ] oh and it doesn't even work but we
could get a sixth injection okay so
they've been empowered and emboldened to
by their own people to do more of the
horrible stuff so yes I suspect that the
things will come back and guess what
they won't come back in red States
Devin says Dave what was the most
shocking and unexpected part of this
election to you and what's your biggest
takeaway and lesson well
I would say in in the broad sense
although I was warning you can't count
the chickens before you hatch I really
did think that there were going to be
some bigger red winds now as I'm taping
this at this very moment
um because we are taping this on
Thursday this is a pre-tape even though
it seems live to you right now we are
taping a little bit early because we had
some other stuff we had to take care of
today uh the Arizona situation has not
been resolved so Arizona still is not
resolved and Nevada is still not
resolved and you got to remember we have
this runoff as we talked about earlier
in Georgia so the Red Wave in effect it
might just be a delayed Red Wave because
if all of those things go red then we
basically got a red wave right we got
there are three more Senators you got
another governor and there you go
Pennsylvania still turned out to be
really wacky and okay so be it
um so I did expect a little bit more of
a red wave but
is what it is
um I would say I I guess it's what I
said yesterday you know coming to the
realization
that a certain amount of people no
matter what you say they just want more
I don't know if it's that they don't pay
attention they don't understand what
their god-given ability is not just the
god-given rights but they're god-given
ability to have autonomy over their life
they don't understand it or they're
afraid of it they're afraid of grabbing
Life by the balls and going and getting
something they would rather just be
these automatons that exist in a world
of video games and ubereats and porn and
whatever else and it's like
we got to get past that a certain amount
of people don't want to be helped yeah
you know what I mean they want to be
helped by the helped by the government
but they don't want to be helped in the
true meaning of help which is help
yourself help yourself and then figure
it out so we do have to figure out what
that is you know what is that what does
that really mean
50
50.8 percent of the people that voted
voted for John fetterman 46 voted for Dr
Oz that 50 thought he was competent and
ready to be Senator and they want to
send him out there to have more power
over their lives like that's crazy but
we have to come to grips with that is
reality for a certain set of people uh
Caesar says what skills have you picked
up after living in Florida seems like
Florida man needs to be able to back a
trailer with a boat down a launch ramp I
don't have a trailer yet and we don't
have a boat yet I would love to get a
boat at some point we don't live on the
water obviously you can have a boat and
not live on the water and they they
gotta you get a dinghy uh so we're I
would love to get a boat at some point
also everything's just crazy expensive
right now because you can't even get
stuff and you know because of the supply
chain which still is having all sorts of
problems and to buy used boats are now
more expensive in many cases than new
boats because at least you can get the
new boat so people are willing to pay
the premium because you can get it
immediately what skills have I learned
um I've gotten I've gotten pretty good
at uh spotting iguanas iguanas often are
somewhere lost in the trees but I could
just be sitting outside and I can spot
iguanas over there they're there they're
everywhere I can get through the
camouflage and I can spot iguanas rivi
it says do you think the race was is so
tight not a red tsunami like some
predicted because so many young voters
turning up and voting uh that have been
brainwashed through the education system
for the past six years so that is one of
the memes that's coming out now that a
lot of young people did vote and that
their default position that factory
setting position is Democrat you know
Unfortunately they think that Democrat
means good and nice and Republican means
uh you know mean and cares about money
or something like that and we got to
break this thing um I think there's
probably some element of that you know
it's it's also fueled obviously by
algorithms and what people are seeing on
Tick Tock and all of these other things
so we have to just make it so that young
people understand what freedom is I can
tell you when I go to colleges and I do
a lot of stuff with with turning point
or uh some of these other organizations
like there are a lot of young people who
really do get it there really are but
there are social pressures there are
social pressures which keep a lot of
them closeted in their political beliefs
or not really fighting for what they
want etc etc look there are social
pressures that will literally have a a
wash of young curls trying to be young
boys right like the trans thing exploded
and Abigail schreier wrote a wonderful
book about this and the evidence Bears
it out that it's not that there's
suddenly 800 percent more trans people
genuinely trans people than there ever
were before it's that social pressures
make young people do things so we have
to change we have to flip the script so
that the social pressure on young people
is you should think freedom is cool I
don't know how you do that I don't you
know these institutions are rotted
they're being taught by really bad
professors and and bad administrators
with the wrong ideas how do you do that
over time well maybe you get your kids
out of school you hopefully do most of
the teaching of values at home and then
you go from there Jesse says how much do
you think red voters fleeing blue States
affected the election results so this
was a big one that I heard that because
there was such a population transfer
because so many we know over 300 000 new
people moved to Florida as one example
but we know tons of people moved to
Tennessee we know tons of people moved
to Texas there were no red people
fleeing to go to Blue States there's
just no instances of that did that
affect this election well I think for
one thing in one case yes right so for
sure it helped the margin of victory in
the red states there is simply no doubt
and I'm sure we'll get evidence of this
over the coming weeks that the red
people let's say who moved to Florida
my two companies alone at least a dozen
people like okay it's a dozen people but
it's just indicative of something right
uh that that that helped the margin of
victory for DeSantis that's one version
the question is did all of those people
moving uh did that affect the outcome in
the blue States my guess is actually no
and and hear me out on this one I think
because if you think about it the states
that lost the most people were New York
and California I didn't even know until
about two weeks ago New York actually
lost more people than California but the
thing is uh California was going to go
Blue no matter what right so they lost
these red people but the the couple
hundred thousand that maybe would have
voted red and even if you throw in an
extra couple hundred thousand you double
the amount of people that left it's like
that still doesn't cover the margin and
even new in New York where zeldin did an
incredible job incredible job and he's a
name we should all know and be thankful
for he really tried to do this thing uh
it's not that enough people had they
just stayed it would have put them over
the edge so that's kind of where we're
at with that Mark says what cartoons do
you plan on showing the wee ones I
haven't seen Looney Tunes in years and I
don't know if they've been canceled but
I love them as a kid I love like you
give me old school Looney Tunes uh well
you can even give me Tiny Tunes you know
Tiny Toons was a little bit behind me
but it came out I don't know it must
have been in like the mid 90s or
something so I was 15 already but the
old school Looney Tunes Foghorn Leghorn
who I did an impersonation of last week
I thought I said I said it was pretty
good uh you give me uh Marvin Martian
obviously The Bugs Bunny Porky Pig Daffy
Duck I always love Daffy Duck I always
love Daffy Duck you ever see Daffy
Duck's fantastic Island what a great
absolutely great movie if you haven't
seen it uh so we'll do some Looney Tunes
I can't wait to you know when they're a
little bit older and I can show them you
know my childhood stuff like you know
when I can show them you know 1984 GI
Joe 1985 Transformers you know and then
I can just hide away the new
Transformers from them you don't need to
see the Michael Bay crap we're sticking
with Hasbro
1985. You've Got The Touch Transformers
if you got that reference I love you uh
all right guys have a great weekend
everybody as always if you want to play
along
reubenreport.locals.com my interview
with Michael shermer's all over the
place and we leave you with what I think
was the most inspiring moment of the
entire week and in case you didn't know
one of the many reasons I'm proud to be
a Floridian we have embraced Freedom we
have maintained Law and Order we have
protected the rights of parents and we
reject woke ideology
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woke and the corporations we will
never ever surrender to the woke mob
Florida is where woe goes to die
oh